y también con nuestro segundo invitado
del día vamos a hablar de las tasas de
interés como ya lo estamos adelantando
con danny de eeuu a propósito de la
decisión de la reserva federal de
aumentar las algo que viene esperando el
mercado hace ya meses y en que nos
impacta más de lo que creemos toda esta
subida de las tasas de interés es que
durante la pandemia la mayoría de los
bancos centrales del mundo dejó sus
tasas en mínimos como una herramienta
para por supuesto ayudar a que la gente
que consumiera más y reactivar así la
economía pero esto disparó entonces los
precios al consumidor empeorados ahora
con la guerra en ucrania también pues la
cadena de suministro mejor dicho todo un
desenlace luego de la pandemia danny sí
señor por eso estamos también con
nuestro invitado porque es interesante
analizar como los bancos centrales
tienen esa tarea tan tan ambivalente
también a veces de decir o subimos tasas
e incentivamos
perdón o bajamos a estas iniciativas
como el consumo o hacemos lo contrario
por eso pues vamos a hablar con los
invitados
así es que nuestro invitado del día
entonces lo presentamos daniil audio
love del ex presidente de la consultora
zenten y el américa latina es director
del hemisferio occidental del fondo
monetario internacional del fm di tan
bueno señor claudio lo saludamos acá en
directo américa y yo puede personalmente
quisiera preguntarle por qué nos debe a
nosotros importar si eeuu sube o baja
sus tasas de interés en américa latina
sobre todo cuando vemos que los países
llevan ya varios meses subiendo tasas de
interés en brasil lo acaban de subir al
11%
bueno evidentemente todos los mercados
en principio están conectados no
hablemos del caso de rusia en este
momento y cuando hay un aumento de tasa
de interés en los eeuu eso lleva a
dos cosas una es que en reacción
inmediatamente el dólar sube en los
mercados entonces en américa latina ya
sea para el peso colombiano para el
para el peso argentino para el peso
chileno o lo que sea
todos
el tipo de cambio se deprecia lo cual
tiene un efecto inflacionario al menos
que suban aún más la tasa de interés así
que tiene un impacto directo en nuestros
mercados latinoamericanos tuvo algo que
ver
claudio la guerra en ucrania con esta
decisión no es simplemente ya una
decisión que las autoridades
estadounidenses digamos en este caso ya
tenían prevista
de rusia y ucrania tiene un impacto yo
diría que es un impacto marginal en la
tasa de la tasa de inflación ha ido
subiendo y alcanzó digamos 7%
para febrero
y eso por supuesto
es lo que ha llevado a través de los
últimos seis meses a que la reserva
federal y apretar los tornillos porque
no queda más remedio la idea es que la
inflación es peor que aumentar la tasa
de interés así que esto puede haber lo
ha
desacelerado un poquito se esperaba que
subiera medio punto porcentual y
solamente subió 025 señor claudio por
qué no explicarle a la nuestros
televidentes también qué implica cuando
un banco central sube o baja su tasa de
intereses o cómo se les traslada
finalmente en términos de ir a
consumirla va a pedir un crédito como es
ese funcionamiento
bueno
todas estas economías
en la mayoría de los países viven con
crédito ya sea las empresas o los
individuos
aquellos que tienen la tasa fija eso no
le afecta es pero en general si yo tengo
por ejemplo pago con tarjeta de crédito
en la tasa de interés en la tarjeta de
crédito va a subir no va a subir
instantáneamente pero casi en el mismo
momento las empresas van a buscar plata
le va a salir más caro el que quiere
comprar una casa o refinanciar va a
tener que pagar más o sea que de la
reserva federal más o menos a 50 cuadras
de aquí al bolsillo de cada individuo le
pega inmediatamente
ahora también claudio yo le quería
preguntar una cosa digamos si sube la
tasa de interés en la reserva federal de
eeuu esto repercute digamos en los otros
bancos centrales de otro país otras
reservas de otros de otros países
digamos que la economía mundial se tiene
el índice digamos puesto en la reserva
federal de eeuu
una vez una de esas preguntas que se
responde con sí y no
los mercados están así de unidos y
por ejemplo la reserva fue perdón del
banco central europeo que tiene una tasa
el que tiene su propia moneda etcétera
etcétera y va a ver que el euro se
deprecia y eso puede ser más
inflacionario porque los precios están
en dólares de muchas cosas el petróleo
etcétera entonces en ese sentido van a
reaccionar subiendo la tasa de interés
para que haya también algo menos de
inflación pero depende de la
circunstancia no es que no es que
siempre que haya que hacer unas cosas en
ciertos países donde el tipo de cambio a
lo mejor está atrasado como puede pasar
en algunos países como mi país de origen
la argentina van a decir no lo voy a
dejar no voy a subir más la tasa de
interés voy a dejar que el tipo de
cambios en el precio
a una respuesta complicada a una
pregunta muy clara y sencilla
bueno voy a tratar de hacerle otra
pregunta muy clara y sencilla usted cree
que esto sí va a funcionar para para
digamos ponerle un freno a esa inflación
que está disparada en eeuu porque en la
pandemia lo que hicieron fue bajar las
tasas al máximo pues para incentivar el
consumo ahora están teniendo otra
estrategia
en la reserva federal tiene como
objetivo principal
bajar la inflación como segundo objetivo
sostener la actividad económica lo que
pasa que la actividad económica está
prácticamente a pleno empleo acá así que
eso es una cosa y por otro lado la
inflación es un mal mucho peor
yo creo fervientemente
de que estas subidas de interés que van
a ser 7 en este año o sea que va a haber
aumento bastante importante de tasas de
interés
es crucial para que la gente no sufra va
a sufrir un poco ahora pero yo diría que
hacia fines de año esto va a tener un
impacto muy positivo digamos ya en el
mercado global entonces claudio a
finales de año podemos contar con una
menor inflación o es muy difícil también
hacer hacer una predicción digamos de
alguna manera
tendríamos que ver país por país pero
tratemos de hacer como algo medio global
o por lo menos en nuestra región américa
latina'
ciertamente que esto va a tener un
impacto positivo en ese sentido en
américa latina va a ir en otra vez en
dos direcciones para los países
importadores de materias primas esto va
a ser bueno porque el precio del
petróleo el precio de los alimentos va a
tender a bajar para nuestros países y
ciertamente en sudamérica que más bien
somos exportadores netos eso va a tener
en esa parte un impacto negativo por el
lado del ingreso pero en términos de
inflación
claramente va a tener un impacto muy
positivo